I want you to clear your minds back to
when we redefined trigonometry and we've
said all the trig functions they
starting triangles but let's move away
from triangles where you stuck on acute
angles and let's move through the unit
circle this guy right the unit circle
allows us to understand not just angles
that are not acute but reader angles
like zero degrees and 90 and 180 and 270
etc and also obtuse reflex this whole
range of anglers right so we redefined
causes sight as the coordinates of a
point on the circumference of the circle
we said it's coordinates or because sine
okay the given a certain angle theta at
the origin like so okay so we did this
and when I do this I sort of on the side
mention to you that I'm this line here
right if I've extended it out so that it
was not just an interval but natural one
they'll pass through the origin okay we
noticed that if this ring here but that
height there is the Y value sorry and if
the horizontal value here up to this
point is cos then in this triangle right
rise over run rise over run is sine of
course which is ten so rise over run
equals ten yeah but of course of course
rise over run is what we define as
gradient right we define that as the
gradient of that straight line that's
passing through the origin so in fact I
don't have to say rise over run I can be
a bit more efficient in that and I can
just say M equals tan theta it's kind of
cool right we've got this relationship
with gradients and and the angles that
they form with the x-axis
now I want to move over a little bit on
this second axis can you see right that
it's not that important that it passes
through the orange
okay I can actually put this line with
this gradient I can move it anywhere I
like instance let's put it over here not
passing through the origin anymore but I
can make exactly the same statement okay
I've got this angle theta Yeah right I
wanted to work out the equation of this
line y equals MX plus B where can I find
its gradient right well the gradient is
in that means if I go one unit across
this just call that one okay
then gradient means I should rise em
units right does that make sense so even
though this doesn't go anywhere near the
origin I can still make the same M on 1
equals 10
statements right because I still have a
right angle triangle I will always have
a right angle triangle when I'm working
out gradient okay so I can use this all
the time I'll let you think a little bit
about special cases of this for instance
this all looks nice and neat but what
year I have a line like this what would
be the implications of that well how
about what if I have a line like this
okay think about how it relates to ten
right if we're saying M equals tan theta
on one more this one's kind of nice it's
going off at increasing rate what if I
said move this out of the way first of
this okay now remember remember when we
measure angles between lines lions and
the axis we're always going to be this
side the answers right the positive side
we go this way and then we measure
anti-clockwise right look here where's
the angle in this case
it's it's obtuse isn't it it's there
well now so again I'm just gonna give
you this is the general idea but you can
see there are some special cases that
kind of mean you need to be really
careful with understanding this okay
it's not that difficult by the way I'll
just give you a really really super fast
example if I put in this line this line
because of what it is you might be able
to anticipate what this angle is just
think about it don't say it right how
would I get that angle without knowing
what it is by using this what's M in
this case it's minus one so I would say
tan of something is equal to minus one
now if you've reached for your
calculator and you said this use this
shift tan button okay it's going to tell
you - 45 in other words it is actually
telling you this angle right from which
you would interpret okay the actual
angle that I want is one good fun okay
so you can't be blind with this formula
this formula takes advantage of a
geometric structure but there are other
cases where you need to be careful with
using